in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Bryce
and Sarah are with us hey guys how are
you doing well Dave thanks how are you
better than I deserve welcome welcome
what are you guys from Columbia Missouri
very nice fun welcome to Nashville and
here to do your debt-free scream yes sir
yes I love it I love it I love it so uh
how much have you paid off we have paid
off sixty three thousand dollars in
twenty six months love it very cool and
making what kind of income during that
time range
we started at forty five thousand and we
ended at eighty thousand okay very cool
good for you guys and so what kind of
debt was the sixty three thousand is all
student loans all student loans of his I
love it what's your degree in political
science okay cool what do you do for a
living I'm a advancement officer at the
University of Missouri perfect and and
what do you do Sarah I'm a graphic
designer
very fun very fun well congratulations
you guys so what happened twenty six
months ago this started the story tell
me about it
sure so we got engaged December of 2012
um we got married June of 2014 but in
between that time period we had a
meeting with her in-laws who were in the
or my my in-laws are your parents who
are in the studio with us and we had a
little sit-down chat and talked to some
things about the wedding but they also
you know talked to us about you know
there's this there's a Financial Peace
University class that I think you guys
would really be interested and that was
kind of like and you can't marry my
daughter if you don't go yeah it was it
was kind of like that you know and I was
a little bit I you know not all in yeah
to marry Sarah obviously it's worth it I
got it got on board yeah I go to one
class yeah yeah you're hooked yeah so
once you got to the class it wasn't as
bad as you thought oh no it was great I
mean I got I could hooked right away and
it was it was really interested in so it
was a good suggestion from the in-laws
good suggestion from the in-laws good
guidance so
very cool yeah I did not require it in
order to give my blessing for my
daughter's hands but I strongly
suggested it I love it
well congratulations you guys so you get
married and you got Financial Peace
University in your pre marriage process
and so you knew what to do as soon as
you get married boom where after the
student loan yes sir so your first goal
as newlyweds kill Sallie Mae kill Sallie
Mae throw the old woman out of the house
that's what we did I love it good for
you
thanks for you you know in a culture
where it's all over the news and
everybody's a victim and their student
loans are killing them you killed
instead yeah you took you took control
of your life you know what's interesting
is is there such a metaphor for that in
your lives I mean it's you know you guys
learn to do something in the first year
of your marriage that some people marry
married 10 years they don't know how to
do and that's worked together to hit a
goal yeah and it causes you it forces
you to do stuff in your relationship
doesn't it yes and it's extremely
empowering for your relationship to I
mean you just when you know you can do
something like this you know you can
tackle anything oh yeah anything yeah
we'll do it together we can do it
exactly so when people find out that you
paid off sixty three thousand dollars
worth of Sallie Mae and they asked how
did you do that what do you tell them
the keys are I always say just have like
allow yourself to dream and so ours we
decided together that we were going to
wait until we paid off the debt to start
a family
mm-hmm to get a house to get a car and
every time we came to a difficult
decision to buy or not to buy I just had
to think what do I want more mm-hmm and
it was always babies house car yeah yeah
more than that thing at Target right
right more important than going out to
eat more important than dot dot fill in
the blank right yeah and I would add on
that you know sacrifice and discipline I
mean your we had to tell a lot of people
no I mean you know we had friends set
off you know one bistec on trips with
them then we didn't do and you know you
just have to kind of discipline yourself
and you got to know what you want in
life and you know this is what we wanted
in life and we know you my Katy grin you
got no dad I mean just like it's really
great so which goal is first
well they're not gonna be mad about for
you guys thank you very fun very fun
what was the hardest part for you guys
well I would say kind of along those
same lines you know I through high
school in college I had this timeline of
what I thought my life was going to be
so to continually think this is where I
would be if without the debt was really
hard for me but you married into it you
know continually it was a blessing in
disguise that we've you know been able
to do this together and they're all so
much more than I think we would have
otherwise yeah yeah I think the most
difficult part was for me was yeah so I
got a new job recently but before that
when we were going through all this loan
it was my first job after graduate
school and I you know I was getting paid
twice every month and so every single
time two weeks rolled around it was
another paycheck going straight out the
door I mean we lived on less than one
income and we just sacrificed and cut
but having to do that every two weeks is
just like the biggest annoyance in the
world it was it was not fun so it'll
make you never go back yeah that's yeah
that's right so for sure well
congratulations you guys I'm very proud
of you I think we're gonna give you a
signed copy of Chris Hogan's new book
number one bestseller retire inspired
excellent thank you so much because
that's your next go go yeah yeah you
know houses babies cars and build some
wealth and you know and be able to live
and give like no one else and man you
you're young you're making great money
you know how to set and hit goals
together hey there's nothing holding you
guys back you're gonna be
multimillionaires
yeah sky's the limit and that's the one
thing I mean that's just amazing to
think about and we thank everyone here
and especially you for giving us this
plan because you know two years ago I
would have no clue about how to do any
of this and now I can see is myself with
a you know a paid-for house at 35 and I
can see myself as a millionaire when I'm
55 hopefully you know I mean it's just
amazing what this plan does and anybody
out there on the radio that's listening
do this you need that you need to get
involved with this and if you're you
know you know worried about taking that
step do it you won't regret it so well
regardless of your age you guys are
exactly new Financial Peace University
was designed for yeah I mean it's any
age goes
but it's people that are ready to change
their lives and we show you exactly what
to do step by step and then here's the
magic you have to go do it we can't do
it for you exactly and so that's what
makes you guys the heroes of the story
we're honored to be with you
congratulations thank you alright Bryce
and Sarah Columbia Missouri 26 months
they've paid off sixty three thousand
dollars making forty five up to 80
during that time count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
love it love it
congratulations you two very very well
done man that's awesome that's exactly
what we do man I love it
so proud of them very very well done hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or $500,000
in the cop